these refugees from Afghanistan and
Pakistan are burning old railroad ties
to keep warm temperatures can drop to
minus 20 degrees Celsius here at night
the smoke burns their lungs and is
hazardous to their health but they don't
have a choice in the warehouses of a
former train station fresh air it's an
anomaly if you go inside and you have to
stay for 10 minutes so you will see and
you will feel that how we have to we are
staying here and if you stay just for 10
minutes so the tears from your eyes will
start and you're not we were just
waiting for the good news from the from
the European they're giving some to one
a window idea in the in the border there
yes we were welcoming these people since
the Balkan route via Hungary and Croatia
was closed they are stuck here some
people began moving into the warehouses
in the summer across from the train
station the square here is now known as
Afghan Square during the week Doctors
Without Borders has a truck parked here
in case any emergency care is needed for
weeks the doctors have been taking care
of people with frostbite bad coals and
whatever else comes up usually skin
infections one half of them is skin
infection and though from that number
one third is the respiratory and the
other one the other problems doctors
here say the people will not survive
much longer in this illegal camp
especially if it stays so cold on
Tuesday the Serbian government moved
some 200 people mostly children and the
sick to an army base in the town of
obrenovic west of Belgrade the United
Nations is alarmed without help from
abroad especially from the EU they
feared the Serbs will not be able to get
the situation under control we are very
concerned about the people living here
since summer the number of refugees and
migrants in Serbia has increased from
2000
to seven over 7,000 now and although 80%
of them are sheltered quite well
sheltered by the government we still
have a number more than a thousand who
live in improvised shelters that like
these here until now the Serbian
government has tried to avoid images
like these getting out and if measures
aren't taken soon many fear the former
warehouses behind the old train station
could be forcibly cleared